this was a terrifying attack just
moments from the victim's school
emergency teams working to save his life
but tragically he died in hospital
the victim kyrie mclean was just 15.
police confirmed he'd been stabbed
seeing him laid on the floor there and
i'm one of my one of my great teachers
trying to help him and the amount of
respect i have for that teacher
is
is unbelievable like just just for him
just for him to do that he was the first
person there trying to help him great
student great great kid and like now now
he is his past and like he can't see his
mum no more today police continue to
search the area
using an aerial drone and forensics
teams the school today issued a
statement saying it was devastated by
the loss of one of their students it
offered its condolences towards the
victims family and friends saying that
they had lost a loved one and the school
here had lost a wonderful member of
their school community
there were no lessons here today but the
school was open for pupils who needed
support this community is in shock and
now scared for their children i live
very close by
and where you live you expect it to be
in
a safe area
and they're only young so us yeah i
worry for them in their future
um i know it can happen anywhere but
i don't i just want to put them in a in
bubba wrap and
leave the house but
yeah it's horrible
a 16 boy from huddersfield has been
arrested on suspicion of murder he
remains in custody
catherine overtopsies sky news in
huddersfield